the fastest way to accomplish anything is to model
someone who has already had the same success that
you are after you can go around trying to figure
out everything by yourself trying to come up with
every new idea yourself and you will slowly slowly
make progress towards your ideas but until you
recognize that success leaves clues that whatever
the thing is that you're trying to accomplish has
already been solved by thousands of people that
all you need to do is model the success Until
you realize that you're gonna constantly say
struggling making slow progress knowing that
you're capable of more so I first learned the
power of my own success with my first business
I was 1920 not making any money 300 bucks a month
low confidence filled with self-doubt not getting
results and I told my partner that I quit and the
thing that saved me when I hit my lowest point was
I am not the first person to try to solve this
problem before maybe my specific scenario yes
biotech software you know from Toronto who's done
that before nobody but a software company get into
a million dollars somebody's done that before
how about I just look at their success and try
to emulate it need motivation watch your top 10
with believe Nation hey it's Nina Carmichael we
made this video it's probably because you're
the most ambitious person in your circle you
know you're capable of more and you get that
punch by surround yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best my husband
Aaron Carmichael and his top 10 rules for success
so I first learned the power of violent success
with my first business where I was struggling
I was I was 19 20. I'm not making any money
300 bucks a month low confidence filled with
self-doubt not getting results you know I turned
down high paying jobs to do this thing and own
30 of a company that seemed to be going nowhere
and I told my partner that I quit and the thing
that saved me when I hit my lowest point was I am
not the first person to try to solve this problem
before maybe my specific scenario yes biotech
software you know from Toronto who's done that
before nobody but a software company get into
a million dollars somebody's done that before
how about I just look at their success and try to
emulate it and so the only person I could think of
off the top of my head was Bill Gates so I looked
at Bill Gates and how it got started and it was
through Partnerships and I applied that lesson
to my business and in a short amount of time had
my first deal for thirteen and a half thousand
dollars I felt like a rich man you know I felt
like holy cow and to go from 300 bucks a month
and and saying I quit to now having a deal in
place for 13 and a half K and more important the
strategy that I could use again and again again
was was life-changing for me all because I modeled
success and that was again when I was 1920 so now
what have I done for the past 20 years is just
model success what is my YouTube channel about
what is this video about a lot of success why have
these people behind me it's not for you it's for
me I want to model success they're constantly
pulling me up to a greater spot whatever problem
you have has been solved not exactly the specific
minutia but by modeling Bill Gates it took me 80
of the way you still have to figure out that final
20 but most people are trying to figure out the
whole hundred that's the problem I was struggling
when I was trying to figure out the whole hundred
all by myself I just come up coming up with new
ideas new ways new innovation but nothing worked
all you have to do is figure out that last 20 and
so look to your Heroes look to potential mentors
whether you know them in person or not they've
done it before they can teach you success leaves
Clues you don't have to go through this alone and
you can ramp up your success really quickly rule
number two fix your thinking how you think about
the problem is the problem most people are locked
into losing thinking finding all the reasons why
you won't win if you're the ant think about how
you can kill the elephant if you're the elephant
think about how you can kill the ant the problem
is not the problem how you think about the problem
is the problem so I used to think that introverts
couldn't win I used to think that to be a good
speaker to have a YouTube channel to to be an
entrepreneur that introverts can't win and for the
longest time I hid behind the faces on my website
so before even starting YouTube I started on my
website it was called devincharmacle.com I didn't
have a better name at the time and I profiled
different successful entrepreneurs basically what
I do on YouTube but on my website because I wanted
to share the stories model and success saved my
business and I wanted to make it easier for other
people to be able to get success on their own as
well so learn who's done it apply those strategies
make it work for you and let's go and so I always
hid behind the faces I remember my first banner
I had Howard Hughes a big Howard Hughes uh Oprah
Winfrey and a couple of people and people kept
asking me well where is Evan Carmichael you know
the website's off your name you're putting this
together what's your story and I thought well who
cares about my story I mean sure I built and sold
my first business but it's nothing compared to how
we're Hughes and Oprah Winfrey's people have done
great things and it kept coming up over and over
and over again translate that to my YouTube
channel Evan Carmichael was still the number
one requested top ten and when I first started
doing top tens we did Kanye West shout out to
Kanye there on the wall and then a bunch of other
people people kept asking for mine like well what
do you want mine you mean again what have I done
compared to Kanye West and I always hid behind the
fact that I was an introvert and so I don't want
to share my story nobody is interested I'm shy
I'm I'm the Wallflower I don't go off and try to
make myself the center of attention I don't like
you know hanging out with people and so I had the
story that introverts Can't Win It wasn't until I
reframed it and thought you know what introverts
can win in Communications because we're better
listeners I'm a great listener as much as you
might think I love talking and making these
videos and seeing the speeches that I do what I
love doing more than that is listening and I think
that's how you win as an introvert because it's
not about you just sharing sharing sharing talk
talk look at me it's you're trying to help and
I've met some amazing introverts who are on a huge
Mission and why not have a big impact and have to
fight with themselves to get out of the comfort
zone and have the spotlight on them instead of
just being behind the scenes but they're all great
listeners they become great communicators because
they're great listeners and so the problem wasn't
that I'm an introvert the problem is how I thought
about the problem of being an introvert rule
number three take control of your this missions
every time you say I can't you're teaching
yourself that you suck because you've quit because
you've given up it's not your fault that you can't
do it it's your work or your school or your family
or all the other commitments that you have but not
your fault nope nope nope change your I can't to
either I'm going to or I choose not to that's how
you take back control of your decisions and your
life so I recently listened to this Chinese song
and I got obsessed with it I got obsessed with it
I was playing it all day long and I just I loved I
don't know what they're saying I don't know which
I don't know what the words mean I just love I
loved it I loved it I go to bed and lyrics start
coming to me rap lyrics in full sentences right
the first one comes in okay wake up I'm in bed
I'm lying in bed trying to sleep you know it's 11
o'clock trying to sleep constant idea rap lyric
come okay I write it down again Rattlers come
write it down more and more and more write it down
until three in the morning I haven't slept yet
ideas just keep coming for this song that's like
I need to make a rap and then what comes into my
head is that what you can make a wrap it's easy
to get locked in into I can't mode I can't do
this I can't start that I can't do a rap I didn't
go to school for that not that you go to school
for rap you know I didn't rap growing up I don't
have musical Talent right that's not what people
know me for that's how people expect from me I
can't rap foreign that's where most people quit
but instead I decided I was gonna get up at three
something in the morning go to my computer finish
writing out my lyrics and then I spent the day
rapping and that night finished the video sent
it off to uh Christina my Editor to put it
together and the next day we released my rap
video now maybe you love it maybe you hate it
it's gotten some decent responses it was tons of
fun to put together and most importantly I taught
myself in all of these things these are all great
micro moments to teach yourself that you're
amazing whenever you say I can't and you do it
that's how you build self-confidence that's
that's the birthplace of self-confidence
self-love self-respect is taking something that
you think that you can't do and just trying
not even doing it full out because I don't
expect my rap to go off and win any kind of
awards right but I tried it I did it I released
it expect the second beginning that's okay it's
normal it's part of the process but in those
moments of I can't and then turning them into
something that actually exists is where your
Genius will come I look at my top 10 series
and partly why I have Kanye on my wall because
the first video that I made was on Kanye first
top 10 was on Kanye was five years into my YouTube
career I did a response to my friend Mark Draeger
from Phantom media and I said initially I can't
do this like I can't make a video now on this I
have all these other commitments I have a full
day ahead of other stuff that I'm supposed to
do and said no I did action I'm just gonna do it
forget it I'm gonna make it and I didn't expect
it to do well luckily it actually did and then
that became this whole thing of making I don't
know how many top tens hundreds maybe a thousand
I don't know how many top ten how many times have
I done I have no idea but it started off as this
idea trust your ideas know that they're amazing
stop saying I can't to yourself this is where
you need to take control of your head and your
heart you have to make decisions with your heart
and then use your head to figure out how to do
it anytime you're doing something new super
important anytime you're doing something new
I'm making I'm gonna make a rap I'm gonna
make a top 10 video I'm gonna do anything
outside my normal thing right same for you anytime
you're doing something new it doesn't make sense
because it's new what is brand new doesn't make
sense you're creating something new and so your
head your logical brain that's designed to keep
you safe doesn't understand it its job is to to
protect you and says don't do that you can't
do that because one has ever been done and
because we have all these reasons why it's not
possible for you not just anybody else for you
that you can't do it because you haven't done
it before that's what your head says your heart
can create something new your heart creates
art your heart makes up a world that hasn't
existed before and so at the very beginning
of many projects you're having your heart or
against each other your heart's saying I want to
make this your hearts think you can't make this
and so you end up staying stuck in limbo with all
these ideas never taking momentum because you're
you're heading your heart are fighting you've got
your foot on the gas and the break at the same
time never moving knowing that you're capable
of more and so you make the big decisions in
your life with your heart and then you rally your
head to say okay we're doing this I'm making the
rap video I'm making the top ten you're gonna do
your crazy idea and then your head says ooh okay
they're serious let's figure out how not to die
doing this right let's figure out how to actually
make it work so you make the big decisions in
life with the heart and then you use your head
to figure out how to go out and accomplish it rule
number four learn to reframe change how you feel
the problem is most of the time we don't catch
our feelings if you're feeling negative angry
frustrated depressed it doesn't matter what the
thing is that you're trying to accomplish you're
not going to give it your all and you're not
going to get results because of your negative
emotional state if you don't start changing how
you feel you're never going to make progress on
the goals that you set for yourself so one
of the things I love doing whenever faced in
a negative situation is say it's the best it's
the best I'm wearing this hat says Fanta because
friend of the channel Mark Drigger pointed out
to me when I was saying it's the best that I'm
a reframer I'm reframing I've never heard of
the concept before reframing means you take
this negative situation and then you spin it
you reframe it so that it's positive so that
it motivates you so that's exciting so that
it pushes you forward instead of it being a
negative thing that is all encompassing and
depressing and brings you down and he said
well you're always positive because you're just
a reframer and it he has his anagram and I'm a
number six or something I don't know he can give
you more details you want to know what number
you are and what it means go follow mark.rag on
Instagram and ask him but I think that's something
everybody can learn how to reframe you take
whatever negative situation that's in front
of you and say this is the best right now this
is the best where this came from was I was on a
airplane from Vancouver to Los Angeles and that's
a five hour flight give or take and I have to sit
next to this really smelly dude and there was no
other option I had to stay on the plane I had to
make my flight I had to speak at this event
the only other option was get off the plane
and it was really smelly I'm sure he didn't want
to be smelly I'm sure that wasn't his you know
intention or ambition it just happened probably
had three stopovers you know I hadn't showered
in in however long and just he's stuck and in
my head I'm trying to find Solutions there's
no Solutions and so I'm upset I'm complaining
you know the 15 seconds of back and forth this
sucks I can't believe it and then here's what
happens in my head I say this is the best this
negative thing that's in front of me right
now this is the best this is my chance to
show myself what I'm made of right and so he's
sitting right here next to me I'll look over
and just breathe it in breathe that
in breathe in that smell breathe it in
to show myself that this is not that this one
dude is not going to ruin my day and I feel
great now about myself because self-confidence
comes from doing difficult things and I just did
something difficult and that's where it's the
best came from it was a it was a quick trigger
to myself to say this is the best it's the best
and now it's become this thing that anytime I'm
faced in a really negative situation that feels
overwhelming and possible just want to complain
find somebody to blame and say it's your fault no
this is the best this is my chance to show myself
and the world what I am made of and so you can
flip it for yourself what is so overwhelming so
impossible so crazy that is bringing you down
you look at your calendar you look at your list
of emails and it's just depressing great this is
the best if you believe like I believe that your
purpose comes from your pain if you believe that
the thing that you struggled with the most in life
becomes your calling for the rest of your life the
time that you struggled and suffered the most as a
human your your purpose for the rest of your life
is to help other people who currently are who you
used to be then that thing that happened that that
massively negative thing the most painful moment
in your life actually is the best because it's
going to allow you to serve hundreds thousands
maybe millions of people through your purpose
so that negative thing's in front of you tell
yourself it's the best also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will highlight
all the Lessons Learned in this video as well as
pull out our three favorite learnings and quotes
that will inspire you to actually do something
the worksheet will also give you space to write
down what your key takeaways are and your specific
plan of action to make sure you're getting results
if you want the worksheet design specifically
for this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click on it
and start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there rule number
five change your calendar most people have not
taken control of their schedules you wake up like
an accident start responding to other people's
emergencies and and help other people build their
dreams instead of you building yours it's time
for a change you deserve better and this video is
going to show you how I think one of the biggest
reasons why so many entrepreneurs don't take
enough action is because when you get motivated
you don't do enough you feel the motivation you
feel the boldness feel the confidence but you're
not taking enough action you're not doing enough
I remember going to my first Tony Robbins event
this is before uh I knew Tony one-on-one before
I did the interview with him on my channel I just
went to see what would the event be like I've
I've seen so many different videos of so many
different people and I felt like you know what for
most people going to their event it'd probably be
the same as just watching on YouTube but for Tony
I felt you know what I think his event might be
different there's something that tells me by going
to his event it'll be different than what I just
see on YouTube through the content and so I went
I went with my wife I went with three people on my
team I paid for everyone to go out and went to
our first Tony Robbins event and at the end of
the last day if you've never been to Tony Robbins
event it's on fire you're you're motivated you're
jumping you're dancing you're hugging you're
high-fiving you're you're breaking through limits
it's it's amazing by the end of the last day you
see everybody in the streets you're pouring out
everybody's all pumped up and energized like I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna do that I remember one of
the people that I brought with me he's like yeah
I'm gonna do all this stuff and he's like yelling
and so fired up and excited he's like what are
you doing Evan like I'm looking at my calendar
because this is why so many people fall
off you go to an event like that and then
you fall off because you're not making a
consistent success is habits so whenever
you decide to make a change you have to at
least for me I look immediately to my calendar
so if my goal is now I want to be a big YouTuber
great when am I going to make videos it's got to
be in the calendar it's not in the calendar it's
never going to happen and so anytime you want to
make a meaningful change you have the default of
thinking what am I going to put into my calendar
because success is habits and so it's great to be
motivated maybe these videos do it for you maybe
Events maybe books podcasts awesome you're getting
it from somewhere you feel motivated great show
me in your calendar where you are spending the
time to actually make the thing happen otherwise
you're just living off some fumes you know you
get motivated for a day or two it feels amazing
and then you fall back down to normal if you
want that dream life you want that next step
for yourself it's gonna come from changing your
habits changing what's in your calendar to make
sure that what you say you want out of life you're
actually working towards making that happen rule
number six build trust if you want to become a
millionaire or influence a million people you
need to learn to build trust this is where you can
really win as an entrepreneur because people have
a really hard time trusting big companies to do
the right thing so this is where you win you win
by not trying to be exactly like the big companies
you win by showing that you actually care and will
do the right thing by the customer so bringing it
to a YouTube world as an example I think everybody
should be responding to all comments one of the
things that I believe in is every comment we try
to get a response to every comment gets a response
every comment gets a response and at the beginning
when you're doing a YouTube channel it's easy
my first video on YouTube it took me a year to
get three comments I made a video within one year
there were only three comments on that video the
first comment was my mom thank you Mom the second
comment was my older sister thank you Alexandra
and the third comment was from some random dude a
new somebody discovered my channel right one year
three comments those are pretty easy to respond
to right it's super easy in the early days when
you're not getting comrades if you're getting a
comment a day a comment a week couple comments
a day it's easy to respond to what happens when
people's scale is they stop responding to comments
because they don't know how to scale the business
because at the beginning they're doing everything
themselves and it doesn't take up a lot of
time but as you start getting more comments
it starts to take up more time I get hundreds of
comments every day on my on my YouTube channel I
can't respond to every single comment personally
myself if I could I could if I did it then I
wouldn't do anything else I'm gonna be making
this video because I was spending all my time
responding to people's comments right that's the
process but just like any other business when you
start a business you're doing everything yourself
if you start selling flowers on the street you're
doing everything right you got to find the
flowers you got to sell the flowers you got
to distribute the flowers you're doing everything
as you grow and as you get a flower store then you
bring on a team right and you have people who
are selling flowers for you and open this door
for you including the store for you you're still
doing work right you're doing more important work
you can't do all of the tasks in the business at
all times if you're always doing everything you're
never going to scale and so I believe that bigger
YouTube channels should hire a team to respond to
comments I have an awesome guy my team named velco
so you'll see responding to a lot of comments and
he'll save the comments that I need to see so if
there's feedback or suggestions or improvements
I want to see them if there's criticism I want
to see it if it's just saying thank you Evan for
the video amazing I feel the love I don't need to
see all of those comments that come in right I'll
I'll sort through some of them respond to some
of them but that's not gonna be the best use of
my time every day because then I'm not making
videos and so make that equivalent for yourself
at the beginning it's easy to show hard and
easy to show care because you don't have that
many customers because maybe you only have one
customer and so you can show them the love but as
you scale and grow how can you continue to do that
whether it's you doing that most important element
yourself because that's the thing that drives it
or you have people on your team that really show
that love and support because you want to make
sure the customer feels respected and appreciated
it's really easy to build trust in a one-on-one
situation it's harder as you build and scale your
clients and so you need to build and skill your
culture alongside rule number seven work hard
hard hard work is your ticket in no matter where
you come from what you look like what your skills
are hard work is always the ticket in the odds
might be against you awesome now what quit on
your dreams or keep working hard how you answer
that question will change your life so I have
an agent in New York and when I first started
the agency I almost didn't get in uh I didn't
get in because I'm a weird case for them my agent
now he looked at me back then and this must have
been six or seven years ago by now and he said
Evan I love your message the problem is you're
not a very good communicator and that hurt at the
beginning because I had already done some speaking
gigs I'd already been making videos for three
or four years you know I've had hundreds if not
a thousand videos already under my belt and here
he is saying that I suck at communicating and he
said the people that he typically works with are
people who are already in media who have tons of
experience who are great in front of the camera
they need help refining their message he said for
you I love your message you've got a great message
you just suck at being a little communicated like
and so okay great well where do we go from
here and he said I'm gonna take a flyer on you
I don't normally do this I'm gonna take a flyer
on you and see where you go and I I didn't want
to waste my opportunity I didn't even know that
you could get an agent as a as a business person
as an entrepreneur as a speaker I mean I guess
I heard a speaking houses but an agent I thought
more entertainment or Sports not for business
so I didn't want to lose this opportunity you
know I didn't want to regret not giving it my
best and so I said okay great tell me what I
need to do I'm the worst right now awesome I I
don't have the skills that everybody else here
has how can I get better what do I need to do tell
me and he said okay so your first challenge is I
need you to make a bio video and I need you
to tell your story a foundation Story video
make it 20 to 40 minutes long and record it
and I'm gonna look at it and I'm going to give
you my feedback on it okay great so I recorded
it the next day and it was in the morning and
recorded it sent it to him he gave me feedback
and then at lunch I recorded it again he gave me
feedback I recorded again in the evening I did
it 30 to 40 times that's a lot over over the
course of how many days you know 10 to 12 days
I guess uh I recorded the video over and over
and over and over and over and over and over
again every time you give me feedback I do it
again feedback do it again and I got better and I
got better and over the course of a couple months
when I was making three videos a day practicing
sucking but just practicing and trying to get
better and listening to feedback and trying
to improve I quickly became the best case
at the agency I quickly became the number one
person from from views from subscribers from
Best Practices I copy what Evan's doing now
I'm being brought on to help them with their
clients and train some of them on how they can
get better on YouTube and build their brand from
being the worst from the guy who almost didn't
get in because the people who are joining them
one maybe had bigger egos but also we're having a
hard time finding the time to make a video a week
and if they're not making a video a week or
having a hard time doing it and I'm making
three a day even if I suck I'm gonna get better
I'm gonna outpace just because I'm willing to
work just because I'm putting in the effort
you might not have the skills you might not
have the talent you might not have the looks you
might not have what you think you need to have
how does an introvert build a huge audience
and and spread a huge message and be famous
on YouTube I don't know I mean I'm working on it
join me on my journey we'll figure it out together
that was my agent's concern when I first
got started and I'm I'm breaking the mold
and doing things in the way that haven't
been done and you can do the same thing
through hard work hard work doesn't guarantee
your success there's a lot of people who work
really hard and never win a lot of people who
work 12-hour days and are doing minimum wage
jobs they're working hard and they don't win
you have to work hard and you have to work
smart but it's not one or the other the people
who were in The Agency were working smart but
we're making one video a week I was working less
smart but making three videos a day so I'm gonna
get better I'm gonna get smarter I'm gonna make it
faster I'm gonna I'm gonna show you what I can do
hard work is always your ticket in and one of the
biggest problems that people just aren't working
either hard enough or smart enough just want
it too soon and you can be impatient and it's
amazing but better than being impatient with
the results is being impatient with yourself
most people are impatient with the results like
it's not coming fast enough like where are my
subscribers or My Views it's not happening my
first video took me a year to get three comments
and the first one was my mom the second one was my
sister and the third was some random dude right a
year to get three comments and two of the people
were my family you're impatient with the results
what you should be is impatient with yourself when
you're not getting results when it's not happening
audit yourself are you putting in the work are
you doing enough work are you working smart
enough are you applying the right strategies get
more frustrated with yourself and your effort more
than that the results aren't there because if
you woke up every day and did that equivalent
of making three videos a day when other people
are making one video a week you will eventually
win it might be slower than you'd like but
it's always slower than you'd like but you
will eventually win because hard work is always
your ticket in ruin them hey develop new skills
you will never lose in life if you have valuable
skills you won't lose your house you won't lose
your car you won't lose your clients if you have
a skill that brings people value the economy can
collapse the algorithms can change but as long as
you have a skill that solves problems for people
you will be safe so I'm seeing this a lot in the
YouTube world now I have a new course out helping
people get to a million subscribers on YouTube
we can link up the description there if you want
in and people are saying well should I still
do YouTube is it too late like YouTube won't
be here in five years or 10 years or maybe it's
gonna be the next thing that should hop on it's
not about the platform like right now it's winning
the platform that is currently winning you need to
crush it right like YouTube should be your home if
you're trying to make an impact you're trying to
be a thought leader you have a message to spread
YouTube has to be your number one place it just
has to be right now otherwise you're not making a
smart decision but whether YouTube is still around
in 20 years five years doesn't matter because the
skill set that you learn you can take anywhere
the ability to communicate you could take to any
platform you could take to the next thing I don't
anticipate YouTube still being around in 20 years
but my ability to make videos talking to a lens
that's not gonna go away that can serve me for
life right whether that's VR Evan or hologram
Evan you know coming into your living room that's
that's gonna be me that's gonna be amazing I'm
pumped I look forward to it any algorithm change
that people are freaking out about anybody who's
complaining about the economy going down or the
algorithm changing you've already lost that's
a losing mindset when I was first starting my
YouTube channel uh I always saw the algorithm
as a chance to win right you should see if you're
a small Creator on any platform YouTube Instagram
anything and the algorithm shifts that's your
greatest Advantage you should be cheering you
should want more algorithm changes if you look
at a traditional established boring Market uh
it's hard to win real estate could be hard to
win right financial markets can be hard to win
not that it's not possible it's just hard to
win because there's a lot of people who have
who have Decades of experience and no more than
you and it's hard to close that gap of experience
with social media with YouTube every time there's
a big algorithm change the people
who are experts at the last thing
they're crying instead of adjusting that's how you
win that's how you get ahead of them that's how
you become the top dog is because you're gonna go
learn the new algorithm when everybody is wishing
and hoping that the old algorithm comes back and
this happens for every platform that happened for
Facebook every time they change your algorithm
or updated the the feed and what was shown there
people always freak out and complain and they
sign they want petitions and like let's go back
to how it used to be don't sign those petitions
don't jump on that penguin that is loser thinking
never ever ever ever ever ever ever do that it's
loser thinking and that's how most people think
that's a mindset shift that I want to make for
the collective but more importantly for you
that whenever there's a big change embrace it go
all in on it learn it that's how you're going to
LeapFrog everybody else so the faster the rate of
change the more you should be cheering I still get
pumped for an algorithm change me I mean now I'm
at now I'm closer to the top right I mean I don't
know what the top is I got two million subscribers
and 300 million views and all these channels I
still love it anytime an algorithm change comes
out I'm still pumped train yourself Like A change
is coming I'm pumped get excited because there's
still people who are ahead of me or even the
people below me that I'm competing with for for
attention and for space if they're sitting there
complaining about how it's changed and they're
dropping in their views awesome I'll pick up
those views because I'm going to learn what the
new algorithm is all about same thing with the
economy when the economy crashes everybody who's
complaining about how it used to be they're not
going to win it's comforted in the join a club and
wish things could be how they used to be but we're
not going back to that So the faster you realize
that and make improvements the faster you can
learn and actually build a great business some of
the greatest businesses in the world are built in
recession in depression that could be you if you
decide to be let's hop back to skills for a second
I look at Jake Paul Logan Paul they started on
Vine right Vine was was their claim to fame they
had tons of success in making these super short
videos Vine gets shut down right boom gone this
is don't put all your eggs in one basket I think
that's loser thinking too it's loser thinking
they went all in on Vine and and then Vine got
shut down oh no what did they do they moved to
YouTube and started crushing it millions of
subscribers look at their growth on YouTube
over the past I don't know two years three years
blew up why didn't just come out of nowhere they
had the skill set they had the skill set that they
learned from doing the thing right the skill set
to make a good video they then brought to a new
platform if YouTube goes away you're learning
the skill set of how to communicate how to make
great videos that whatever comes next people are
freaking out about the FTC coming in and Kappa on
YouTube okay so if kids aren't able to get content
on YouTube where they gonna go go be there instead
of trying to fight what is already happening
go be at the place where the kids are going to be
embrace the change that's where you that's where
you can win what everybody else is fighting and
angry and screaming and yelling and complaining
and wishing that it used to be or quitting the
platform and getting upset go be where they're
gonna be it's it's easy it's a simple win most
people don't have that mindset it's why most
people lose why most businesses can evolve most
most businesses shut down it's people very rarely
transition from one platform to another from
one business to another even though they have
the skill sets and capabilities to do so because
they don't have the mindset to do so people who
crushed Myspace very few of them are still around
on different platforms look at look at Hollywood
the rock is doing it Will Smith is doing it moving
from Hollywood films to YouTube where's Brad Pitt
where's George Clooney like they're in a dine
industry they should be embracing YouTube they
don't want to they have the skills they have
the skills it's transferable you don't think
George Clooney could come in and Crush YouTube if
you wanted to of course he could calling you out
George Clooney let's go make it happen all right
it's just about picking up the skill set that will
keep you safe in any environment but it's also
having a mindset to follow through and try the
new things that I'm complaining about the changes
that are currently happening Rule Number Nine stop
complaining the easiest way to win is to do work
that you love making a new video is easy for me
I've done 6 000 plus videos I still love them and
still enjoy it but there is a chandelier sitting
in the trunk of my car right now that I have no
interest in installing I have I have no idea how
to install a light I have no interest in learning
how to install a light and so I've asked my friend
Mark Draeger from Fanta to come and help install
the light for me if you're doing a business that
you don't know and that you don't love and
you think it's just going to be easy money
newsflash it's never just easy money you're going
to lose you have to go through what I call the
blinders test now blinders are things that people
put on horses so there's those black patches that
they put here on the side of the horse so the
horse doesn't get distracted so the horse isn't
like going all over like this all they can see
is what's in front of them and it forces them to
just focus and go in front of them now side note
apparently they actually have this for humans too
and some tech companies are using them where they
have blinders for humans that seems a little crazy
to me but listen if blinders help you focus then
by all means go for it but you need to pass the
blinders test so what is a blinders test for
me it's those moments in time where you have
absolute Clarity for what you need to do where you
know where you want to go where you have Direction
and purpose and this is the window that you need
to jump through for me right now it's YouTube
yes I've been on the platform for over 10 years
but this is a special moment in time for YouTube
right now for Evan Carmichael plus YouTube right
now I'm hitting it on strides we've got I don't
know how many channels right now a lot too many
maybe but I want to have a hundred channels this
is a moment in time YouTube's not going to be
around forever and it's going to morph and it's
going to become something else and I'm gonna
have different interests at some point this
is the moment of time that you need to then push
hard I see opportunities as Windows there's this
window that's in front of you right now and the
windows open but it's not going to be open Forever
at some point that window of opportunity is going
to shut and that's when people look back and say
I had as I could have done it and and that other
person they made so much money off of my idea it
wasn't your idea they did it the only difference
between you and the people who are winning is they
started they did it they take action every
single day there's no reason why that person
can't be you you have to jump through the window
with full force and put your blinders on and stop
thinking about everything else that's around you
that's if you have absolute Clarity and direction
now there will be other moments in your life and I
think I think life moves like this I think you'll
have moments in life where you have absolute
Clarity and purpose and Direction and there'll
be other moments where you're not so sure what to
do and then you have to open up the funnel again
sticking to the blinders when you don't know
what you're doing is not a great strategy this
this happens to a lot of entrepreneurs where they
have focused for their business but then they lose
interest in their business and then they bought
themselves a job and they're too afraid to get out
of that business because of what it means because
of the opportunity cost because of everything that
they've they've sunk into the business because
people might say well what a failure if they
close now and they should have been out of their
business three years ago but they're still going
don't let that be you you're never gonna win doing
work that you hate if you don't like your business
anymore you need to adjust it or you need to move
on dump it move on to something else if I stopped
liking videos I will just decide no more videos
happening sorry guys maybe sell it to somebody
else or just stop because I'm not going to win
doing work that I hate either and so if you feel
your foot kind of pulling out of the water while
you still have some interest move on to the next
thing and so when you know what you want to do
you're focused hyper focused that's all you're
doing when you don't know what you want to do
you open up the scope and that's okay and I think
everybody will go through these phases in life you
will have absolute Clarity and so you need to go
off and do instead of finding all the reasons why
you can't do and when you don't know what you want
to do don't stress out and worry that you don't
know what you want to do try a bunch of stuff say
yes to everything pay attention to the feeling the
most important thing when you're trying something
new is do you love the process of it not is this
going to be your next big opportunity did you love
the price even though you suck doing it I sucked
making my first video I love the process I sucked
when I first learned salsa dancing I love the
process you're supposed to suck at the start
that's okay you don't need to get instant results
if you love the process you will win if you got
instant results but you don't love it you're never
gonna win it's just never gonna happen you're not
gonna win and so depending where you are on this
spectrum of absolute Clarity to having no idea
dictates what your action should be when you
know what you need to do stop making excuses
stop having justifications and just go off
and do the damn thing and if you don't know
what you want to do then explore stop feeling
sorry for yourself stop complaining it's okay
explore you will find the thing that then you
can focus on until the next time you expand it
rule number 10 love the process a good question
to ask yourself is do you actually love this do
you want it badly enough I love making videos
I sucked at the beginning I'm still working to
get better I've gotten better over the you know
decade I've been on YouTube I still look forward
to it I still love it I still work every week
creating content for you guys we're putting out
six videos a day across the different channels
now it's it's wild it's crazy and I still love
it we're putting in the work I'm putting in the
work my team's putting in the work because we
still actually love the process of doing it so
so many entrepreneurs quit and give up because
you'll say you'll do whatever it takes but
you're not going to if you don't actually
love the process you don't actually love the
work you will not do whatever it takes you
will only force yourself to do something that you
hate for so long until you give up and quit so a
big reason why entrepreneurs don't put in enough
work it's because you just don't love it enough
if you're not happy right now it's probably
because you're not growing humans want to
grow we want to learn we want to improve we want
to get better we want to feel like we're making
meaningful progress somewhere and when we feel
like we're learning and growing and the work
that we do matters we feel great right if you
felt great when you learn the new skill when you
when you help somebody out when you felt that the
work you were doing was meaningful it felt amazing
but if you have too many days in a row or you
feel like it's too hard it's too big you're
not growing you're not learning there's there's
no hope that leads down a really dangerous and
negative path not where we want to be and part of
why we become entrepreneurs is because we want to
grow right because we're we don't want to have
a crappy boring job working for somebody else
wasting our talents away I remember my my I didn't
have that many jobs I had a landscaping job which
is super boring just every day just rolling
out of grass and then I had a data entry job
where this really turned me off of the
corporate world where I was doing the work of
we had six people five people on my team and I was
doing more work than all of the others combined
and I didn't take lunch breaks I just I just
kept working and my boss wasn't happy that
because I was overhead lighting gave me headaches
I used to have to bring in some snacks like food
or popcorn or carrots or something so I didn't
get crazy headaches and my boss didn't like
that I was eating a snack while I was working
and I got in the trouble and almost got fired
even though I was doing more work than my
entire team combined and it just really
turned me off of the corporate
world to realize hey this is
this doesn't make any sense I wasn't growing
you know I wasn't learning I wasn't improving
and so you can examine your own life if you
feel like you're in a rut chances are you
haven't learned anything recently and so we can
we can plan for this you know you can change your
schedule so that you can focus on learning
you can put it into your daily calendar and
this is where I think it becomes the greatest
benefit my greatest tactic or strategy for you
for myself is schedule in learning schedule in
growing so for me it's my own videos you know I
make these videos hopefully for you that you learn
and improve and something Sparks for you but I'm
making for me I'm making for me because I need it
because I need to be around people who are doing
big things and that I know that every day there's
a video for me amen it's it's going to be positive
it's going to be uplifting it's going to spread
believe it's going to be motivational or inspiring
it's going to be Tactical and I know that on
my channel I'm going to get content that I want
and so I've hired a whole team and built the whole
business basically around making content that I
want to watch and thankfully enough of you guys
want to watch it as well that it it I can build a
business and have a team but if I didn't or nobody
else cared about it I would still do it for me you
know it may not be as fancy may not have as much
intros and all that stuff but I would still have
it for me because I need it and so we tend to
catch these things too late because it's not part
of our habits and routines so if you notice you go
to an event or you watch a video and you get all
inspired and you're you got energy and you're
working and things are amazing cool and then
have weeks or months gone by and you realize what
happened to me what how did I fall off the horse
so quickly where did my energy
go has that happened to you
chances are is because it wasn't scheduled you
know part of the entrepreneur roller coaster
is because we're bouncing from one high to the
next without having any scheduled in learning
and growth and so my challenge to you would
be to try to figure out how can we schedule
in learning and growing every day and so it
starts with figuring out okay what medium do
you like the most you know for me I like videos
I like being able to see stuff it just makes
it so much easier for me I'm a visual learner
before YouTube was a thing I learned from books
that was the best thing available at the time now
I still have a habit of reading 10 pages at least
a night but I don't get most of my learning from
books I get most of my learning from videos but
for you maybe it's videos if you're watching
this maybe it's books maybe it's podcasts
something like where do you get the best learning
and then the great thing about where we are right
now is there's so much content there's so
many people to learn from there's so many
people creating things out there that you can
go and learn from them you know if I look at
an Eric Thomas or an Oprah Winfrey they have a
similar message just a different delivery style
and so whatever you want to learn chances
are somebody's already making content on it
and so just go and find them and think about who
you're following right now like do an audit of
who you follow right now we fall in on YouTube
we'll be following on Instagram or Tick Tock
or what podcasts you listen to or what books are
you picking up and how many of those people that
you're following are subscribed to actually make
you feel ambitious and hopeful and better about
yourself and give you strategies and light you
up and feel like you're learning and growing
right that's the whole point of this we're trying
to make growing and learning a consistent habit
so how many people that you're following actually
make you want to learn and grow and how many of
them are you just mindlessly scrolling through you
know when you load your Instagram or your YouTube
when you're just scrolling and scrolling and
scrolling and two hours have gone by and not only
have you not learned anything you feel worse about
your life because now you haven't been productive
you know you just kind of mindlessly entertained
yourself but it wasn't even that entertaining
you're like what just happened to the past two
hours of my life has that happened to you cool
unfollow those people it's not that they're bad
people because that content doesn't light you up
and then start to be around the people who do
and the easiest way is through content so if
it's my channel hey good news we've got content
every single day for you you'll never run out of
having Chronicle content to watch but it could be
somebody else it's somebody else in marketing or
business or entrepreneurship or person development
or whatever category you're in to subscribe
to those people and be around them as much as
possible and watch your videos every day schedule
it in for me I go for a walk every morning call
it my believe walk I just like getting some sun
on my face and fresh air and getting out of the
home and it just gives me some perspective and
a little bit of motion and helps me set up
my day and then I'll I'll have a video going
from my channel and um every morning
will be somebody else it'll be
Elon Musk or Oprah Winfrey or Mel Robbins
or Tony Robbins or garyvee or Tom Billy or
whatever and that's what we do is pull the
best clips that I would learn from and then
we share with everybody else but that's a
part of my daily routines and I've I've seen
my own growth and development and learning and
bravery and courage and momentum and consistency
be directly contributed and correlated
to the content that I'm consuming daily
and so step one is to unfollow and unsubscribe
from the people who just make you waste time feel
worse about yourself get Envy or just mindlessly
tune out and step two then is to figure out
I need to make learning you need to make learning
growing a part of your daily habit and so where in
your calendar can that fit if it's over breakfast
if it's a morning walk if it's a afternoon lunch
like where in your calendar can you put learning
from your preferred Style video podcast books
Etc learning into your daily calendar if you did
that your life will change if you did that every
day for the next year every day if you did that
if you scheduled that in and you actually did it
and you you watch your video write a book or
listen to podcasts that inspired you said you know
what I can do this I can do more I can be more I
can accomplish This I Gotta stop thinking small
and stop doubting myself and stop telling myself
that I suck and I can't do it I can't do this like
if you felt that energy every day from watching a
piece of content that you intentionally put into
your habits routine every day for the next year
your life will totally transform you will be a
totally different person which then allows you
to serve more to help more to make more money
to guide more to be a leader more all of it all of
your Ambitions and dreams everything that you want
is all possible but you have to factor learning
and growing into your daily consistent habits
and routine focus on one idea and make it work
focus on one business model focus on one Revenue
stream focus on one social media Network and make
it work so many times we're focused on too many
things we're distracted and our entrepreneur
ADHD kicks in and as a result nothing happens
for all the people who are telling you to have
13 different passive income streams because if
one goes away you still have all these other 12
most of people who start off doing that make zero
money from all of the passive income streams
you're making ten dollars a month four dollars
a month seven dollars a month where instead if
you could focus on one thing and maximize it
and make it amazing and put your energy into
it you will see exponential results I look at
social media as an example and I just finished
this training where we did the seven day built
to serve challenge it was amazing had so many
awesome new thought leaders coming to the program
people have got a big message want to serve and
one of the questions I kept getting asking is
how do I be on every social media platform how
do I be everywhere how do I get started and just
blow up everywhere and it's like you don't right
the answer is don't don't don't try to do that
if you are the person right now who is trying to
be everywhere look at your social media accounts
chances are you're sucking everywhere chances
are not not you suck as a human just the results
aren't there the effort's not there the energy
is not there because you're so forcing yourself
to just get out there and create content
and be in all the platforms that you also
have a million other things that you have to
do and so as a result you're you're creating
really mediocre content content that people
aren't interacting with and if people don't
like what you're putting up it's not going to lead
to results for your business and so much much much
much much better it doesn't mean that you can't
be there you know it doesn't mean that at some
point you can't be there that as you build your
brand and you get bigger and you hire a team and
you have more money that you can start to do this
but much better at the beginning is to figure out
what is the one platform what is the one
Revenue stream what is the one business
model the one thing that if I focus on that thing
it's going to lead to results so then I can scale
entrepreneurs have a hard time with this because
we want to do so many things we have our add brain
going on and we don't want to just do one thing we
also feel like it is limiting for what we want to
do right if you have a big Vision a big mission
a giant goal for what you want to accomplish
doing just this one little piece of it feels too
small the way that I would structure it and think
about it is this is just a sequence you still
get to do everything you still get to do it all
you just have to go in order you have to create a
sequence that the thing that you need to focus on
at the beginning of your business whether it's
your Revenue stream whether it's social media
success whatever it is what you have to figure
out is how do I start to as soon as possible get
a sustainable business for myself so that I can
quit my job if you have one so that I can bring
income in for myself my family so I can start
to afford to hire a team even if it's part-time
or one person so you can scale up your company so
that I can then go off and do all the other things
because some of your ideas are are amazing and
huge and require more people and time and effort
and energy and some of the ideas can get started a
lot faster and so if you want to go and accomplish
your big goal your big dream your big mission
then it's important to think about the sequence
of things that instead of doing everything all
at once and as a result all of the results being
mediocre focus on the one thing that if you
push that lever you really maximize that thing
you could start to make more money you could
start to have more impact you can start to have
more reach you can start to see more success
that then allows you to bring on more people
to help you build and scale for me we've got 37
people on the team now and I can do so much more
you know because we got team then if it was just
me by myself doing everything and so in building
my mission I want to solve the world's biggest
problem right people don't believe in themselves
enough and so in building that up I need people
I need help I need support I need team I need
I need a lot more than what I've got right
now but and be able to build a business that
can bring in money then I can afford the higher
team that helps me accomplish a lot more things
and take on a lot more projects but if I was at
the very beginning of what I was doing right now
I would not be doing most of the things that
I'm doing right now I'd still be accomplishing
and going after the same mission but I'd have to
pick one thing to focus on I picked the one thing
at the beginning that I think I could make some
money doing this so that I can live I can I can
pay you know rent mortgage I can pay my internet
bills I could pay for some food not not living
you know fancy life but just being able to
live and survive so I don't have to have a
job and then I would start thinking okay how do
I then scale this one thing that I'm working on
to build up to the point where I can remove myself
or at least take some of the pieces off so that
I can hire a team to help build and scale and
grow if I look back at my YouTube Journey here I
did everything at the beginning you know I I uh I
filmed it I researched it I edited it I did all of
it and it took a crazy amount of time and I made
a lot of mistakes and I did a lot of stuff that I
probably shouldn't have done and just by focusing
on that thing and making content and creating
videos it then allowed me to make a little bit
of money but then I could hire my first part-time
editor that then turned into a full-time editor
that turned into a second editor and a research
person that turned into someone helping with the
thumbnails and the graphics and it continues to
build up in scale but everything I was doing
myself in a mediocre way but getting it done
to then be able to scale out a team and so most
people are just stuck doing too many things you
start look at what you're doing on a day-to-day
basis look at your calendar you have a limited
amount of time right you have a limited amount
of time there's only so much you can do in in a
day in a week you have other responsibilities
maybe you have a job maybe you have a family
kids health that you have to look after you
know there's a certain amount of time that
you have that you can dedicate to this thing
that time needs to go into the right efforts
and again it's great to have that big mission and
big goal and big dream but if you have a limited
amount of time every day or every week and you are
trying to create 13 passive income streams with
that limited amount of time no one of the streams
ever gets enough energy enough effort Enough of
Your Mind space enough of your creativity
Enough of Your Love to ever become anything
and so you're diversifying way too quickly
you're diversifying way too soon and apply
that for anything that you're working on
apply that to your your business and the
and the opportunities that you're chasing
the Partnerships that you're looking at the
things that you're saying yes to the social
media networks that you're trying to be on
do yourself a favor don't try to be everywhere
not yet right just understand there's a sequence
to things and you can make it so much easier
for yourself to have more impact to make
more money to have a bigger influence to be
more proud of yourself to start getting more
success and more results and more momentum
so much easier if you just sequence it out
so that you don't have to do everything all at
once you don't have to feel the the handcuffs
and the Restriction of saying well I don't want to
do this one thing for the rest of my life this is
where it gets you know entrepreneur Ade kicks in
right and we don't want to be locked in I don't
want to do the same thing forever well you don't
you won't do it forever that's not the point the
point is not to do this one thing forever that if
you took these 10 opportunities in front of you
you could do all 10. you could do all 10. just not
all 10 at the same time because if you do all 10
at the same time none of them are going to work
out and often it's a small opportunity that can
pay you more quickly that can start to build the
momentum for you so if you have your list of your
10 opportunities in front of you 10 things that
you could do great look at what order should I go
in so I can start making money and start building
momentum one last quick example I look at a lot of
thought leaders a lot of people have a message a
lot of people want to be speakers and authors and
coaches and influencers and they've got big goals
and big Ambitions for what they want to create
when I'm helping someone like that usually the
first option is coaching the best thing to do at
the beginning is coaching so we're going to dive
into one specific business model right if you can
look at let's say be a speaker uh getting brand
deals as an influencer writing a book and coaching
if we had those are four opportunities in front
of you right let's say so what did I say being
a speaker getting paid to speak getting paid
to do brand deals getting paid to be an author
and selling books um even selling courses your
own materials and training and Etc and coaching
those are those are you know four or five
different business models that you can go
through perfect at the beginning which one is
the best what should you focus on be coaching
why people don't like the idea of coaching because
you're trading your time for money right I don't
want to trade my time for money okay well what
are you doing right now you know you're at a
job because if you're at a job you're trading
your time for money if you have unlimited time
to figure stuff out and you have you have a giant
bank account then you can do something different
but if you need to start to make money to build
this thing up then yes you're trading your time
for money but it's a faster path to get you out
of your job and into your business full-time
where everything else takes a lot more time
speaking takes an incredible amount of time if
you want to if you want to be a paid speaker and
and get paid enough that it's actually meaningful
it takes a lot of time for you to get good at the
skill as well as for you to build up momentum in
the name in the industry you have to do a lot
of free speaking gigs before you ever get paid
to do it so if you have a horizon of years awesome
but I'd rather you start getting paid immediately
while we work on a speaking career you want to
be an author and get paid to have a book cool
you can go and sell publish a book right now if
you wanted to you can get it out you'll make you
know you can sell it to your friends and family
your your audience you'll make a a few bucks but
it's not going to be anything meaningful to get a
paid deal or to have a significant even if you're
going self-publishing to make a lot of money
off your book you have to have a big audience
to get the deal with a publisher they want you to
have at least a hundred thousand followers that's
like your starting point to get in so is that
achievable of course but now we're looking at
years as a horizon as opposed to like this has
to happen right away so you're not getting paid
right now off of your book so if you're sitting
there thinking right in the book creating a great
manuscript creating a great how-to guide it's not
going to be the thing that helps get you any kind
of money anytime soon and I want you to get paid
because most people quit too soon on their ideas
or they're trying to do a million different things
at once right if you're trying to create a course
same thing you have to build up enough
momentum you spend so much time making
a course creating the content filming videos
or writing instruction manuals or creating the
PDFs or whatever your course structure
is it takes so long to make the course
and then you have to go and Market the course and
people don't know who you are yet you don't have a
brand yet so could it work absolutely will it pay
you more than coaching yes absolutely most likely
it's way more easy to leverage that than coaching
but again the timeline is so long and most people
quit too soon on it where if you were coaching
you can you can make money right away as long as
you have something that can actually help people
right if you're good at what you do you know how
to solve somebody's problem you can make money
as a coach right away and yes you're trading
your time for money but it's better than having a
job and it also gets you closer to your customers
at the very beginning I'm much I'm a much bigger
fan of selling a service than a product because
it gets you closer to your customers you get to
know their problems you know their issues you
know what exactly they're struggling with and you
can help them solve it which allows you to create
a better book a better course a better product
because you've worked with enough people through
the problem and so most entrepreneurs fall into
the category I want to do all of it great I want
to be a speaker I want to be an author I want to
create my course I want to create my book I want
to be a coach I want to do all of it awesome
you have a limited amount of time every week
to work on all five of those things at the
same time means there's very little progress
how if that's you and you've been writing your
book how long you've been writing your book for
like when is it going to come out what year how
many speaking gigs have you done in the past
three months all right how much time has gone into
your course it's like we start and stop and start
and stop because we're tackling so many different
things because you want to do it all and you want
to have income streams coming in like crazy and
there's nothing wrong with that it's amazing but
there's a sequence there's an order that if you
can as soon as possible inside of your purpose
start to make money start to build momentum start
to be able to bring on team to help you it's so
much easier you can go so much further you can go
so much faster you can have so much less stress
you can have such a big impact that you just need
to focus you just need to focus it's all possible
your big dreams are possible go in order figure
out the sequence that will start to get you paid
Focus if you want to go Brick by Brick to make it
stick you have to pay attention to two critical
pieces the first is mindset the second is action
you need both or you're going to give up on your
goals you know you're capable of something bigger
but you'll give up because you don't have these
two simple things settled out I'm going to show
you how to fix them in this video step number
one is mindset what you think you're capable
of is what you're actually capable of if you
think you can go off and do it you're much more
likely to do it but if in your head no matter
how many skills and resources and people are
telling you you're great if in your head you
don't believe you can do it guess what's gonna
happen you're not gonna do it and so you can
apply Brick by Brick in a methodology that I call
Big Y little y your Big Y is the big reason why
you're doing this thing why are you doing this
thing your purpose comes in your pain you got
a big goal big ambition you want to change the
world you have a huge impact right you want to
solve giant problems and change people's lives
right that's your big why you want to put a dent
in the universe right you wanna you wanna make
an impact that's beyond your life it's a huge
why I'm waking up trying to solve the world's
biggest problem I don't think people believe in
themselves enough I'm trying to solve the world's
biggest problem I think that's the world's biggest
problem I'm never gonna solve it even if I touch
a billion people I'm never gonna solve it that's
I think you should wake up and have a big why
so big that you're never going to accomplish it
you're going to climb forever you're gonna be on
your journey forever forever forever it's the best
and oftentimes that big mission that big Vision
you have is so motivating for you that it gets you
out of bed gets you motivated like let's go here's
what I'm trying to do and it gets you pumped up
but sometimes the big picture is too big sometimes
your Big Y right is Big Y little y sometimes the
Big Y is so big that you feel you can't do it
that you're not capable that you don't have the
skill sets that you'll never be capable and so
you throw in the towel because it seems too big
and I get that too you know I'll look at me and
my goals of solving the world's biggest problem
and say who am I to solved the world's biggest
problem right how how am I capable of going off
and doing that and especially in my I'm trying
to think the last time I thought about that
especially in my earlier years as an entrepreneur
I really struggled with that I I go do a speaking
gig and and be so fired up and so motivated like
man I know I'm crushing it I'm helping people so
much it's amazing this is this is oxygen this is
what I'm breathed is amazing thank you so much
and then I wake up the next day and be back to
normal like oh can I do this I don't know if
I can do this because there's lack of momentum
and so that's where the little y's come in and
the little why is the reminder that what you
do is important I think it's I think it's so
important that you feel that the work that you do
is important if you woke up and felt every day the
work you do matters means something it's having
an impact man the commitment level you're going
to have is so much greater than if you feel like
nobody cares what's the big deal meh okay so how
do you remind yourself that the work you do on a
daily basis is important to at least one person
that's the little why the Big Y is a big Vision
big dream big big mission like where are you going
awesome the little lie is you may not be able to
help a billion people but you can help one just
reminding yourself that you help one person how
I get that now is in my YouTube comments even now
as part of my morning routine I go to my YouTube
comments and I just see what people are are saying
and these are people that you you know amazing
people who many many of whom I've never met and
maybe never will meet hopefully hopefully meet
you come on my tour meet me on tour probably
I won't meet most of you and to see the warmth
and the love and the and the comments that you
guys are leaving makes me feel like this is why
I do it this is why it matters this work matters
if I stop doing this it would it would mean
something to people and they you'd have to go
somewhere else no not so full of myself that you
couldn't find another solution but the work that
I do matters and your comments feed me every day
I'm spoiled now that we get hundreds of comments
and tons of DMS and lots of messages that come
in Daily but when I was first getting started
I didn't get that money when I talked about my
early days as a speaker I would speak and have a
great time and then the next day wake up and feel
like what's the point I would say the thing that
made the difference was I would save the messages
that people sent me or emailed me or said at the
end of one of my workshops and I would put them
together in a PowerPoint file and I would watch
that PowerPoint file every morning that became
part of my morning routine this is when I really
first started doing morning routines this is this
was such an important piece for me was showing the
messages from these people as a reminder every day
that what I do makes a difference and maybe I will
never hit my billion but these 18 people that I
helped I helped them that was me I did that right
if you felt like you helped some people every
single day even if just remembering old people
that you helped every day as a reminder it'll
give you the ammunition the momentum the fuel
that you need to keep going every day so Brick by
Brick sometimes it's Big Y right it's the mindset
sometimes it's the big why sometimes it's just
man I'm gonna go crush the world I'm so excited
I'm gonna go solve this giant problem and and
change Humanity right sometimes you feel like that
and it's amazing and you go you go you use that
boldness and energy to create something amazing
and sometimes you're going to feel like I can't
do that big thing and so you just look at the
comments you look at the the one person that you
helped or the five people that you helped or think
back the people that you have helped in your life
to remind yourself that you are valuable that you
make a difference and the work you create is
Meaningful and to get the momentum and energy
you need because for the most part the biggest
thing you're missing is just momentum and momentum
comes from mindset if you believe you can create
great things you can so Brick by Brick starts with
mindset Big Y and little y so I said there were
two things right there's mindset and then there's
action so step number two is action so you you
think you can do something then you have to go
off and do it thinking it is not enough you got
to do something you got to act on it and Brick
by Brick here is we often will plan this giant
thing right you have this bold Vision this big
idea amazing and you default into planning mode
and you think I gotta do this and this and this
and this and this and this and this and this and
this and it's exciting and it's fulfilling it's
amazing to think in planning mode of what you
can potentially build but then you step back
and look at that Behemoth that you just built in
your head or on paper and you think wow that's
really big to do that I need I need venture
capital I need Partners I need I need I need a
team I need and all this all the stuff that you
need that you don't have and then that becomes
scary and then you don't act and so I believe in
what I call the two percent difference the two
percent difference is as soon as you come up with
an idea we're taking immediate action on the first
two percent so what we typically do is we'll plan
to get to 100 you'll plan to 100 you'll plan your
your entire Vision out until it's complete right
then that becomes too scary instead of planning as
your first step plan is important but it's not the
first step your first step is action your first
step is doing your first step is the first two
percent what is the first two percent version so
if your plan is to build the next YouTube channel
it's gonna dominate the world I love it it's easy
to think well I need a camera personally the team
I need an editor and I need a scriptwriter I need
I need I need I need anything great awesome two
percent difference take your phone make a video
today teach yourself to go from idea to action
idea to action the smallest possible version
that little video you make from your phone what
difference is going to make not a lot in terms
of output but a ton in terms of momentum a ton in
terms of momentum most people just don't start if
you want to lose weight you want to get in shape
the best thing you can do is do 10 push-ups right
now I had a person on one of my Lives who said
that their goal was to to get in shape okay great
go do 10 push-ups right now don't don't come back
on into the live until you've done 10 push-ups are
those 10 push-ups going to actually make that
person lose 20 pounds of course not but the
difference between no push-ups and 10 push-ups is
the whole game because if they do that 10 push-ups
they taught themselves to go from idea to action
idea to action idea to action that's the thing
that's missing for most people you have great
ideas I believe you have Michael Jordan level
Talent that's something you're not acting enough
not in a big enough way not consistently enough
there's too much time planning and thinking and
over analyzing and worrying about judgment instead
of just getting out there and actually doing so
planning is important it's just not the first step
you burn all of your boldness and creativity and
energy on the planning you wake up the next day
and you think I can't go do that big scary crazy
thing or instead as soon as you get the idea the
best thing you can do with your energy with your
boldness with your confidence in that moment in
that idea that you just created is go do something
about it and teach yourself that you're the kind
of person who comes up with great ideas who trust
their great ideas who doesn't over analyze anymore
and just puts them out into the world and
builds momentum that's going Brick by Brick
because you made it this far in a video I
want to celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually follow
through most people say they want something
but they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are special
believe Nation you made it here all the way
to the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe down in
the comments Below on this video I will showcase
you and celebrate you somewhere on the screen
in a future video because you are awesome if
you want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you there
why do you get depressed after you accomplish
a goal you celebrate a goal for five minutes
and then you're sad why is that it's because
you had the wrong goal your goal should
not be to climb to the top of the mountain